hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
lektion 7 hört zu und spricht nach
hilfst du mir hilfst du mir ja ich helfe
dir ja ich helfe dir
nein ich helfe dir nicht nein ich helfe
dir nicht
siehst du gern filme siehst du gern
filme ja ich sehe gerne filme ja ich
sehe gerne filme
nein ich sehe nicht gern filme
nein ich sehe nicht gern filme fährst du
gern beelow fährst du gern velo ja ich
fahre gern wie du ja ich fahre gern will
nein ich fahre nicht gern will nein ich
fahre nicht gern will gibst du mir deine
handynummer gibst du mir deine
handynummer
ja ich gebe dir meine handynummer
ja ich gehe
hier meine handynummer nein ich gebe dir
meine herren die nummer nicht nein ich
gebe dir meine handynummer nicht hast du
kinder hast du kinder ja ich habe kinder
ja ich habe kinder
nein ich habe keine kinder
hallo ich heiße daniel und komme aus den
usa
ich arbeite als bankangestellter
ich arbeite als bankangestellter am
dienstag und am donnerstag fahre ich
immer mit dem velo zur bank am dienstag
und am donnerstag fahre ich immer mit
dem velo zur bank ich laufe immer am
mittwoch am abend im park ich laufe
immer am mittwoch am abend im park
am montag gehe ich nach dem deutschkurs
mit tina in ein café am montag gehe ich
nach dem deutschkurs mit tina in ein
café sie erklärt mir die aufgaben und
wir trinken kaffee und essen kuchen
sie erklärt mir die aufgaben und wir
trinken kaffee und essen kuchen am
donnerstag lade ich sie dann ins kino
ein
am donnerstag lade ich sie dann ins kino
jeden freitag treffe ich nach der arbeit
freunde jeden freitag treffe ich nach
der arbeit freunde
wir gehen in eine bar wir gehen in eine
bar am samstag putze ich die wohnung und
wasche die kleider am samstag putze ich
die wohnung und wasche die kleider am
sonntag kann ich ausschlafen
ich stehe meisten spät auf am sonntag
kann ich ausschlafen
ich stehe meisten spät auf und lese beim
frühstück die zeitung und lese beim
frühstück die zeitung
ich fahre ich fahre
du fährst du fährst er sie es fährt er
sie es fährt wir fahren wir fahren
ihr fahrt sie fahren sie fahren
ich treffe ich treffe
du triffst du triffst er sie es trifft
er sie es trifft
wir treffen
ihr trefft ihr
sie treffen
ich lese ich lese
du liest du liest ihr sie es liest ihr
sie es liest
wir lesen wir lesen
ihr lest ihr liest sie ließen sie ließen
ich ich die rechnung
die rechnung der architekt der architekt
nach nach rauchen brauchen die schiere
die schere der schlüssel der schlüssel
schwimmen
mit schlafen schlafen deutsch deutsch
[Musik]